there is a military unit in the woods
equipped with machines that weigh 46
tons
but they are very difficult to find
hidden in the forest not far from the
front line a tank crew work on a t-84
it's a precious piece of kit the
ukrainian military's only got six of
them
although it can be difficult to start
[Music]
vadim and andre are on their third tank
now they lost the first two under heavy
fire
the russians have more vehicles and
artillery at the front
here's what happened the first time
it's become a feature of this war the
crew documenting the scene from the
battlefield
they seem to realize they've had a lucky
escape
one says he's tired
the head of this secret tank base is a
youthful 21 years old and officially
graduated from the military academy on
the day of our visit
but lieutenant timoshok
you're not that experienced you're
you're 21 years old and you're you're
leading the unit yeah yeah which is
[Music]
has already distinguished himself say
his men repelling a russian advance last
week
[Music]
once again the action was caught on a
smartphone
and they've captured five russian
vehicles including two tanks stolen
under the noses of their enemy they say
a crew member called roman went to get
them
down
their opponent is formidable far better
equipped
but there is plenty of spirit in the
woods
the russians can be defeated says the
units commander but they'll have to be
smart to survive
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine